sì sono il trombettista di jazz sapete
tutti che sono nato a berchidda piccolo
paese non lontano da qua che sono
soprattutto figlio di un pastore
mio papà faceva il pastore viveva in
campagna io ho passato la mia
giovinezza con le pecore con le pietre e
bellissime quelle della gallura
anche se becchi te nel logudoro
ovviamente modellate dal modellate dal
vento
mio papà era un pastore
che viveva una vita complessa ovviamente
come tutti i pastori molto legata al
ciclo della terra un circo complesso
quando sono diventato grande
mio padre mi ha detto fai nella vita
quello che vuoi ma non fare il pastore e
poi si è capito perché in questi ultimi
anni era un pastore ma era lo stesso
tempo un poeta come tutti i pastori un
poeta che aveva un forte legame con la
terra
un poeta che avrebbe voluto studiare
avrebbe voluto sognare qualcosa di più
ma non ha potuto farlo perché la sua
famiglia non poteva permetterselo ma che
aveva fatto la terza elementare
molti anni dopo una quindicina d'anni fa
luigi offeddu un giornalista
importante venne a berchidda per fare un
articolo sul nostro festival di jazz
incontro anche mio papà insieme a tante
altre persone e scrisse sul corriere
della sera quella mattina un pezzo molto
bello in cui disse ho incontrato anche
il padre di paolo fresu che ha fatto la
seconda elementare
io feci vedere questo articolo molto
positivo a mio papà che si arrabbiò
moltissimo perché abbiamo fatto la terza
e disse adesso devi chiamare il
giornalista e devi dirgli che cambi il
articoli si papa è uscito il pezzo
stamane su un quotidiano nazionale non è
possibile cambiarlo lui si procura una
penna e cambiò l'articolo scrivendo che
ha fatto l'asse la terza è la seconda
elementare
era un poeta che scriveva come tutti i
pastori in sardegna come tutti gli
agricoltori scriveva in sardo scriveva
poesie scriveva dei piccoli romanzi
molto naif ovviamente ma soprattutto
aveva passato la sua vita a raccogliere
parole le parole desuete quelle che si
stavano perdendo quello che fosse oggi
ci sono totalmente ahimé perdute se non
c'è qualcuno che poi le ha riordinate
per esempio pietro caso proprio a
berchidda con uno dei vocabolari più
importanti della lingua sabbia insieme a
tantissimi atti ma lui questo non
interessava non interessava raccogliere
parole per perché queste poi
diventassero un libero diventassero un
vocabolario interessava a raccogliere le
parole perché era il suo modo di
relazionarsi con la vita con la memoria
con quello che aveva quello che aveva
vissuto e lui aveva una grande memoria
ho scoperto da grande nel momento in cui
mi sono messo a riordinare tutti i suoi
materiali sul mio computer tutte le sue
poesie centinaia e centinaia di poesie i
suoi romanzi prendevo i suoi quaderni li
portavo in viaggio in giro per il mondo
e mi mettevo su un aereo magari da roma
a new york a riordinare questi quaderni
senza che lui lo sapesse e lo scopo
scoprì poi che aveva raccolto circa
7.500 parole vocaboli berkey daisy e
oltre a questi so fra stimo le bestemmie
oltre a questi i nomi delle persone di
una volta e tanti nomi tutte le varie
desinenze di giuseppe piuttosto che
pietro piuttosto che a trino e che aveva
raccolto il numero di cavalli che negli
ultimi 50 anni avevano abitato
nelle terre intorno a berchidda ex si
ricordava anche tutti i nomi dei cavalli
anche tutti quelli che erano stati i
proprietari
ad un certo punto ho stampato questo
materiale o stampato queste parole ho
stampato questi queste poesie e in un
natale di molti anni fa io
rilevato questi libri
e lui rimase
sconvolto da questo regalo ma ovviamente
non era al corrente e mi disse nella
sconvolta ovviamente nel re dei re
riordinato tutto questo materiale che
apparteneva alla sua vita fosse 40 anni
di vita ma soprattutto mi disse ma tutte
queste parole stanno dentro quel
computer dove tulli emesse gli ho detto
sì papa tutte quelle parole possono
stare dentro un computer e possono
starci le molte di più
e allora mi feci una mi disse guarda
non l'ho mai detto perché mi vergognavo
perché lui gli ordinava queste parole
quando in campagna magari pioveva quindi
noi non aveva modo di uscire allora si
richiudeva in casa e aveva dei tanti
fogliettini piccolissimi e al momento
opportuno lui come un lapis scriveva una
parola la parola che si ricordava quella
parola poi la teneva in tasca spesso
questi fogliettini erano magari le
ricevute di un acquisto fatto oppure
erano le ricette del veterinario delle
vacche o dell'euro delle pecore e mi
disse mi sono sempre vergognato di
questo ma adesso ti ti racconto una
storia dice quando io ero in vigna
perché tutti come tutti i pastori era
anche un agricoltore e un e appunto
aveva la voce da vigna che se quando io
non mi ricordavo o meglio quando io mi
ricordavo una parola ma non avevo in
tasca nulla per scriverla dice staccavo
un pezzo di sarmento dalla dalla pianta
e annotavo per terra la parola è quella
parola 2 il giorno dopo sarebbe stato il
giusto computer nel quale depositarla
per fare diventare la qualcosa di
importante la terra quindi quella idea
di memoria molto semplice molto banale
ma estremamente ricca e preziosa
nel 1988 sono diventato musicista
professionista o meglio sono diventato
jazzista professionista prima intorno al
vi starete chiedendo come mai uno di
berchidda diventa un musicista di jazz
non so
non ponete di questa domanda con non me
la pongo io so solo che c'era una banda
musicale che ho suonato nei complessi di
musica leggera per tanti anni nei
matrimoni nelle stesse nei carnevali
tempiesi fino a un giorno in cui ho
scoperto questa musica ma questo è poco
importante ciò che importa è che da
figlio di pastore
nel 1988
grazie a una meritocrazia della quale
giuseppe ha parlato ho potuto comprarmi
una casa
la prima casa che ho comprato
era una
casale nell'appennino tosco emiliano
vicino porretta terme e perché non
potevo permettermi di comprare una casa
a bologna anche dalla città nella quale
viveva e comprare questa casa
nell'appennino una vecchia casa molto
molto romantica molto emozionante come
un vissuto importante vicino alla linea
gotica dietro questa casa c'erano pochi
ancora i crateri delle bombe del 43
e
entusiasta fiero di questo acquisto
portare i miei genitori a vedere questa
casa quindi andare a civitavecchia
andati a prenderli con la macchina e poi
facciamo il viaggio di ritorno per
allevarli a questa casa si accedeva con
un vialetto un dialetto in sterrato io
insieme alla camera ho comprato qualche
ha due ettari di terra era una terra
semplicemente incidentata dalle bombe
della seconda guerra mondiale niente di
più ma c'era una terra intorno
arrivammo a casa dopo un viaggio
decisamente lungo io fermare la macchina
mia mamma che ancora in vita mia non c'è
più
immediatamente scese dalla macchina
entrò in casa e andò a vedere la cucina
alla camera da letto le finestre
tutte queste cose mio papà scese dalla
macchina e rimane
silenzioso a guardarsi intorno e io lo
osservavo da dalla porta di casa e mi
chiedevo cosa stesse pensando se se
stessi amando quel luogo e
chissà cosa pensava dopo un quarto d'ora
mi avvicino il di kobe e papà e allora e
mi disse bravo hai più alberi di me
quel concetto di terra di cui parlavamo
all'inizio di quel segmento che serviva
per scrivere una parola in una terra
arata che era quella di una vigna si
declinava seppure in una maniera diversa
in una idea di bene di dtt di qualcosa
di prezioso che ritornava sempre
l'elemento della terra come
fondamentale in quella in quel col
pensiero
allora visto che oggi si parla di
adattabilità
parlo anche un po di mia madre che
ancora in vita cioè 96 anni e tiene
ancora i conti nella mia casa di
berchidda quella in campagna appunto
dove ho vissuto non gli posso dare
i conti del mio commercialista che sono
complessi ma li potrebbe farli benissimo
secondo me potresti anche assumerla
nella banca perché non state sue 96 anni
è ancora perfettamente lucida e come
tutte molte delle donne sarde quando mia
madre veniva appunto con mio padre negli
anni successivi spesso sono venuti a
trovarmi in quella casa mia madre si
portava lo zucchero e il sale
mi diceva perché lì dove a fare sas
casadina si doveva fare le serate doveva
fare i ravioli
io poi avevo un freezer gigantesco pieno
di cose con cui campavo tutto l'anno e
faceva una grande figura con i miei
amici mi ospita quando in una casa
perché lei diceva che i suoi dolci le
sue paste fatte con lo zucchero che
comprava a bologna non uscivano bene
e io provavo a spiegargli che forse era
un problema altro ma a un certo punto ho
smesso di spiegare questo perché la sua
convinzione in fondo era quella giusta
cioè i suoi il suo zucchero e il suo
sale come quale riempiva le valigie e
poi di dolci ne faceva tanti ovviamente
erano l'unico motivo perché per cui quel
dolce potesse essere buono giusto e
funzionale a quello che lei voleva
questo torna un principio di stabilità
che molto dei sardi in quanto noi siamo
in mezzo ad un isola e non è vero poi
che i sardi siamo così nella di sulla
difesa noi sardi siamo dappertutto siamo
nel mondo siamo nelle posizioni spesso
più importanti della della società i
sardi sono aperti sardi sanno essere
abbraccia persa che poi si chiudono con
quelli che non gli piacciono e allora
sono problemi veri ma questo è un altro
argomento sono tre tipologie di sardi
una la prima quella alla quale afferisce
ancora mia madre perché sono convinto
che se lei ancora venisse a bologna si
porterebbe il suo sale sullo zucchero le
pera di sardi che sono convinti che
tutto quello che c'è in sardegna e
meglio degli altri
le nostre salsicce sono più buone di
tutti non parliamo del formaggio
ovviamente con mia madre continua a
parlare in sardo ovviamente anche se a
casa o dei continentali oppure a
qualcuno che viene da parigi da londra
ma questo è un altro argomento un
argomento di di dinamiche idt di
idiomatiche che poco a che fare con
quello di cui parliamo ma tant'è quindi
esistono i sardi che pensano che tutto
quello che noi abbiamo in sardegna e non
parliamo purtroppo solo del cibo e
migliore degli altri
ci sono poi i sardi che pensano che
tutto quello che viene da fuori e meglio
di quello che abbiamo noi ahimè e questa
è anche ancora una buona quantità di
persone e poi finalmente ci sono i sardi
ad armi pari
quelli che semplicemente girano per il
mondo
si portano la propria salsiccia il
proprio formaggio
entusiasti di condividerla con gli altri
ma allo stesso tempo pure assaggiano il
formaggio degli altri la salsiccia degli
altri sapendo che probabilmente potrà
essere buona quanto la nostra se non
anche più buona questi sono i sardi che
a me piacciono sono quelli che
permettono alla sardegna di crescere
permettono alla sardegna di dialogare
permettono alla sardegna di apprendere
permettono alla sardegna di mettere in
circolo una dinamica di pensiero di idee
e di creatività e costruiscono un isola
che può diventare un vero serve nel
nostro mediterraneo misura dalla quale
le cose non devono necessariamente solo
partire perché sono migliori non devono
sicuramente solo tornare e quelle degli
altri sono migliori ma semplicemente un
server è un qualcosa da cui le cose
partono e dove le cose poi ritornano ed
è questo partire questo ritornare a mio
avviso che
ci permette di leggere questa isola
verso un futuro di un'adattabilità che
non è necessariamente un piegarci a
quelle che sono i bisogni degli altri ma
è un adattabilità che ci permette
solamente di essere interconnessi e di
poter conoscere il mondo attraverso lo
scambio attraverso il dialogo in fondo
se ci pensiamo bene questo scambio
quello che mi milioni migliaia di anni
fa facevano poi da tarros o dai porti
del dei dei greci e dei romani verso il
mondo tutti sono venuti in sardegna
tutti hanno preso tanto ma non è che noi
siamo stati con le mani in mano abbiamo
appreso abbiamo preso una cucina
che viene dalla dal sud da chi viene dal
maghreb che viene dalla spagna abbiamo
preso una musica straordinaria
che un insieme di musiche che vengono da
tutta l'area del mediterraneo
abbiamo preso una lingua che
straordinariamente ricca e
straordinariamente unica laddove questa
unicità
credo che sia effettivamente
l'elemento che oggi permette o
permetterebbe alla sardegna di essere
molto più dinamica nei confronti del
mondo
è un momento storico in cui tutti
parliamo la stessa lingua che momento
storico in tutti le stiamo nello stesso
modo di un momento storico in cui
mangiamo tutti le stesse cose nel
supermercato troviamo tutto quando penso
che in sardegna ci sia una straordinaria
unicità che dovuta proprio a questa
insularità che noi possediamo di
un'isola che riperimetrata in un mare e
che se per molti è vista come un dramma
per altri per me è vista invece come una
straordinaria opportunità
perché quando ho iniziato a suonare in
giro
per l'italia e avevo 25 anni quando poi
è nato anche un festival di jazz
berchidda era parliamo del 1987 1988
nel momento in cui saltavo il mare e
andavo dall'altra parte mi rendevo conto
che gli altri mi guardavano come uno
diverso
ma a me questa diversità piaceva tanto
la diversità derivante dal fatto che io
parlavo pochissimo per esempio il
batterista del mio gruppo oggi ho dovuto
in un'intervista alla rai ha detto
quando ho conosciuto paolo pensavo fosse
molto
perché effettivamente noi sardi quando
andiamo fuori o parliamo tanto oppure
stiamo veramente in silenzio e magari
guardiamo e contiamo con gli alberi che
ci appaiono nate dal finestrino di un
treno mi rendevo conto che ero diverso
perché essere sardi è diverso perché
abbiamo una storia in conosciuto su
connottu come dicono a nuoro questa
parola bellissima e misteriosa che era
che raccoglie tutto su con noto
significa identità significa sardità
tutte quelle parole che pensiamo siano
totalmente vuote e che spesso sono
effettivamente ma laddove la parola su
con no tu mette insieme un vissuto che
appartiene ad un passato ma che quello
che ci forgia quello che ci crea e
quello che ci dava oggi una una
personalità e quindi anche il mio modo
di suonare era diverso io ero il
trombettista al trombettista su una vola
tromba sicuramente meno bene di tanti
altri con cui mi incontravo in quel
momento a roma oa milano
ma il mio modo di suonare diverso e
quella diversità mi ha permesso poi di
potere di poter raggiungere dei
risultati più velocemente probabilmente
di tanti altri che suonavano
perfettamente bene come miles davis o
come c'è più belle che in mare quali
mancava una una diversità della quale
probabilmente c'era bisogno e qualora
quella diversità
secondo me è una risposta corretta a
quell adattabilità di cui stiamo
parlando
perché essere diversi oggi significa
avere una ricchezza che è fondamentale
ma avere questa ricchezza fondamentale
significa non necessariamente pensare
che la nostra salsiccia sia più buona di
quella degli altri ma semplicemente
significa portarci appresso quella
salsiccia trovando a condividerla con
gli altri perché gli altri avranno in
qualcos'altro che noi non abbiamo ed al
quale potremo potremmo imparare
torno verso mio padre e tu non hai poi
chiudono verso mio padre
dal quale sono partito con quella idea
di terra da quell'idea di memoria che
forse la nostra il nostro bene più
prezioso
c'è stato un momento in cui ho pensato
di pubblicare questi libri che avevo
fatto e di continuarli lo sto facendo
tuttora in realtà
ma
credo di aver preso la decisione a
questo punto che quello di non
pubblicare mai quei libri perché quella
idea di un pezzo di di vite che capace
ancora di scrivere la poesia di una
persona di quell'umanità alla poesia di
un albero che conta più di una finestra
più di una casa continua per me ad
essere il bene più prezioso che porto
con me ancora che spero di non
dimenticare grazie
[Applauso]